oh no man it's Gary Vaynerchuk hey
what's going on buddy
life is good you bro I'm good I watched
all time you actually helped me get out
of a depression mode of mine and dude I
love you I'm inspired so much by you
that a lot of people say I'm a lot like
you well I appreciate that man that
makes me really happy
anything I can answer for you well we
just yeah dad's having kidney failure
and I'm trying to find a little bit of
motivation to keep on going with this
businesses having and kind of screwed it
up a little bit and I'm not kind of lost
on what to do and I don't know if I
should just go ahead and start my own
and let him see what he can do by
himself or what well okay let's break
that down for a minute because obviously
that's intense and there's a lot of
emotion behind that is the business and
like do you not know how to operate the
business like one of you know if you're
doing it out of nobility and you know
honor but you're not capable you know of
running it you know obviously you don't
want to put yourself in that vulnerable
spot does that make sense yeah
understood I appreciate the authenticity
does does he want you to do it like does
he need it like give me one more layer
of context and see if I can give you any
value he wants me to take it over but at
the same time he still wants to have his
thumb and control I see no one I mean of
course I know what you mean look I think
you know for me the right answer in
these moments is for you to be overly I
mean it's such a complicated
conversation right like it's a really
tough one but I you know I think you've
got to make a decision there's only two
moves here you either go and have a real
conversation with them and be like that
I really want to roll this for you but
like I need the autonomy otherwise it's
half pregnant or you just eat the [ __ ]
and have the empathy at the macro and
just try to navigate through that them
given the circumstances right right
right
you know what I mean yeah
I'm also trying to open up my own
business as well
what kind PGR business paintless dent
removal if this is X I work from my dad
and I do body work I got it I'm trying
to trying to do paintless dent removal
I'm getting ready to go to school here
and in about six months how old are you
28 got it I mean look you got your whole
[ __ ] life in front of you I think 28
a tricky number because people get
confused cuz your post kind of that
college era 30s looking you in the face
and I think there's an enormous amount
of confusion in the system for twenty
eight year olds about where they are in
life I think that's my biggest problem
I've been having lately and that's I've
been watching a lot of you and watching
a lot of your videos and a lot of things
that you do and all kinds of other stuff
and it's helped me kind of come out and
realize you know my plan is is what I
ever find it I got my own clock a
hundred pro honestly no joke I feel like
you're closer to two point eight years
old than the way you think about twenty
eight like you've got [ __ ] 60 [ __ ]
years of execution in front of you
that's like two [ __ ] full life's more
of execution and and the problem with 28
is 28 so [ __ ] tricky thing 28 [ __ ]
tricky 28 is [ __ ] too many people up
because I'm telling you that looking at
30 like wait a minute I go [ __ ] thirties
here shouldn't I quote-unquote have my
life together you know and then at 28
you got you know five to 50 percent of
your friends that you went to high
school or college with that are like you
know getting married having you know get
getting somewhere in their life that it
uh don't let anybody else's [ __ ]
clock you know dictate your game like a
you know 28 is early as [ __ ] yeah you
suppose me really bad because they're
all buying houses or 2526 buying houses
getting married having kids and brother
their [ __ ] life has nothing to do
with you yeah well why I've watched so
many videos of yours I snapped out of it
and realized that my life is my life and
nobody control it and I'm going to be my
own happiness nobody else can control
that that's what's up man and honestly
like [ __ ] like I just that makes me
happy and honestly I hope you're I hope
it's really sinking in and it's not just
early words
on your mouth because once you go there
once you real dude honestly brother I'll
shoot it [ __ ] straight to you I'm 42
years old and I swear on everything I've
got
I feel like I'm just starting and
everything that people think I am and
what I've accomplished and all that is
[ __ ] in my own head cuz I'm like I
haven't even [ __ ] started so imagine
what I think about you at 28 yeah I did
I watched my girlfriend
I left well I couldn't tell you how many
friends I've thrown away I couldn't tell
you how many friends I just stopped
talking to because there's they're
losers
they're not winners and they don't have
that ambition they don't have goals in
life they have nothing listen some of
the most painful things that so many
people at 28 need to do is cut out
negativity or people that are not going
to the next place
like cutting out all that [ __ ] is
enormous Lee enormous Lee impactful that
makes me happy man I think I think
you've got what I've been doing just
keep cutting until and if there's one
person that's happy left and that's how
you do it
and if there's nobody [ __ ] manifested
in your own [ __ ] dome do 28 is the
beginning all the negative out I'm so
much [ __ ] happier so much happier
brother what makes me happy thanks for
callin bro thank you
[Music]